the story of my my boy oase
who went i think it was philly and he
was visiting the community there he had
some business
and they they connected him with some
brother there's the masjid or whatever
you know how you like bro
i'm going to philly can you hook me up
with someone just to pick me up at the
airport
and they say yeah no problem no problem
so we'll hook you up so the guys you
know he flies there from canada
he arrives at the airport and this big
big african-american brother's waiting
for him you know
he's all tattooed on his face on his
like everywhere you know he smiles
got like golden teeth gives him one of
those big hugs squeezes the life out of
you and
he always like i was like whoa you know
like i was like what's going on
and you know they're driving and he's
like it was he's like at the beginning
he was like you know it's nice like
you know and then he asked me like so
what do you do you know what's going on
he's like you know
some business just got out of jail i was
in jail for 30 years you know for like
murder and
okay so which hotel you're going to drop
me off
no hold on bro you're not going to go to
any hotel it's hot on for you to go to
hotel
you're going to stay with me i'm going
to take care of you bro don't worry
it's like okay don't worry ah i got you
you know
so he's like mashallah they slept like
babies
wake up pray fajr they ate together you
know
drove him around spent he's like few
days together he was like he was the
nicest brother ever man and he says
i'm sure if you wanted to snap my neck
he would do it with like you know two
fingers we just go
you know like that's literally how he
looked like you know but he's like he
was the
nicest person ever subhanallah
and just he said look how islam how
islam takes over
changes you just
it just it's just totally totally you
know it doesn't matter where you're from
doesn't matter what your background
doesn't matter what you've done in the
past doesn't matter
who you are when you become a muslim and
islam
penetrates your heart the depths of your
chambers
it just it just takes over you man it
just changes everything
as the prophet saws said he said when
islam will enter you
take over them you know let them enter
for dunya for whatever but if islam
takes over them
then it will it will change that
[Music]
subhanallah
[Music]
[Music]
do what you can stop worrying about what
you can't um
and again you go to hell you go to hell
i'm just playing um if you think you're
going to go to hell
it's probably because you're not doing
everything you could be doing so
i do say do what you can don't worry
about what you can't but
what people think they can't is often
much smaller than what they actually can
we feel me like people think they can't
do a lot of things
but trust me nothing is farther from the
truth
today and welcome back to the realest
podcast in the dunya
today and we're continuing with the
intimacy series bismillah so how did i
do
it not bad
all right now i'm just playing that take
one was enough let's go right in
yes how are you guys doing um on this
beautiful day
in ramadan alhamdulillah sixth day man
subhanallah
beautiful you're one day ahead of us
because last time you said the
the fifth day and i was like well it's
the fourth day for us
he's sometimes one day out of us he's 12
hours ahead right
okay yeah okay so right guys right now
you guys are fasting the fifth day
yeah we're on the fifth day yeah yeah
because we just started fasting right
now so yeah i'm doing that
actually we are on the fifth day
another's on the fourth day
okay they're having uh one day before
right i mean no no
no no i messed up that's okay yeah
it was it was tuesday and i was like i
woke up i was like
i think i got to do something today like
there's something important that i do
i was like i was remembering the
conversation with uh rami and fayette
and they were like yeah yeah
um we start so and so on tuesday and i
was like
we start after my on tuesday i was like
okay cool so i
ate i did my thing and then like when i
talked to
to fire at nighttime i was like
bro and now he i called him he's like
yeah i'm just i just got done fasting
i'm like wait what do you mean
he's like yeah today was day one i was
like no
that's okay i'm sure i'm sure i think
you know there's a i think the pakistani
community is fasting
uh on your on your time time scale uh
anger pakistanis right i think
right
it really goes to show that you know you
could look like a pakistani you could
look like a
you know you could look black you could
look white you could look asian you
could look russian
but you're still muslim what's your
background bro
i'm from bangladesh no way no no no wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
i thought all this was the
african-american
i mean african canadian whatever you
know but definitely no not bangladesh
bro
are you kidding me well like bro 100
how'd it been like a hybrid
what language do they expect bengali
bengali
that's here what do you want me to say
just to introduce the podcast yeah yeah
uh
bro why are you gonna put me in the spot
i speak i i understand so i can you know
i can
i'll speak to you let me see if you know
what i'm saying all right listen
how are you damn bro
this man is like how are you speaking to
those languages i speak english i speak
spanish
i speak portuguese too
yeah tiny bitter arabic because
obviously you know the players yeah
uh i know i know some thai
i'm learning tigers i'm gonna be going
to thailand soon gabriel
know a little bit because you had a
pakistani wife once upon a time
uh still alhamdulillah still there
yes yes but yeah you guys were talking
about this uh
it's it's amazing how you know united we
are i mean angel you
you you wouldn't you passed i mean
you're 100 latino bro when i look at you
it's like yeah
for real people think i'm dead people
think i'm there i go into planes and
people just give me this
yeah actually no now that you're saying
that yeah you would pass for an error no
doubt
yeah when when i started speaking
spanish they're like ah yeah you're
latino
yeah when you speak you're latino yeah
yeah you know
for sure but subhanallah um just before
yeah we were talking about the
universality of i mean subhanallah just
now
before getting on i recorded a short one
about the universality of islam just a
short reminder
i was talking about the the story of
my boy oase who went i think it was
philly and he was visiting
the community there he had some business
and they they connected him with some
brother there's
the masjid or whatever you know how you
like bro i'm going to philly
can you hook me up with someone just to
pick me up at the airport
and they say yeah no problem no problem
so we'll hook you up so the guys you
know
he flies there from canada he arrives at
the airport and this
big big african-american brothers
waiting for him you know
he's all tattooed on his face on his
like everywhere you know he smiles
got like golden teeth gives him one of
those big hugs squeezes the life out of
you and
oh he always like i was like whoa you
know like i was like what's going on
and you know they're driving and he's
like he's like at the beginning he was
like you know it's nice like
you know and then he asked me like so
what do you do you know what's going on
he's like you know
some business just got out of jail i was
in jail for 30 years you know for like
murder and so always like
okay so which hotel you're gonna drop me
off
no harambro you're not gonna go to any
hotel it's haram for you to go to hotel
you're gonna stay with me i'm gonna take
care of you bro don't worry
it's like okay don't worry i got you you
know
so he's like mashallah they slept like
babies
wake up pray fajr they ate together you
know
throw them around spend he's like few
days together he was like he was the
nicest brother ever man and he says i'm
sure if he wanted to snap my neck he
would do it with like you know two
fingers we just go
you know like that's literally how he
looked like you know but he's like he's
the
nicest person ever subhanallah
and just he said look how islam how
islam
takes over changes you just
it just it's just totally totally you
know it doesn't matter where you're from
doesn't matter what your background
doesn't matter what you've done in the
past doesn't matter
who you are when you become a muslim and
islam
penetrates your heart the depths of your
chambers
it just it just takes over you man it
just changes everything
as the prophet saws said he said when
islam will enter you
take over them you know let them enter
for dunya for whatever but if islam
takes over them
then it will it will change them
subhanallah so
it's a beautiful thing that we're
connected you know from all over the
world
the muslim ummah is you know i mean yes
we're weak yes we have a lot of issues
no doubt
because of many reasons there are beyond
the scope of this podcast maybe one day
we can talk about that
as to you know the history of how we've
reached this point
but uh hamdad
the brotherhood is still there we're
still together
you know look at us i mean canada anger
where are you
you're in uh uh florida florida florida
kuala lumpur he's in florida now he
moved back from afghanistan
no i'm serious yeah you're an
afghanistan
no no no no weren't you serving in like
the war and then you found islam there
i'm serving in the mental war the mental
war
that's the toughest war too i had a
question the brother you were talking
about did he find islam in prison
yeah he found islam in prisons there's
that
um so these there's a few of my brothers
that i look up to and i've you know
uh been with in canada and you know i
talked to them still and there are
chaplains in
in the jails in um you know in the
states or canada what not
and ibrahimovic being one of them
allah blessed him as a african canadian
brother
and these guys work the jails for a long
time
and there's a huge phenomenon it's not
like a one-time thing it's like
i think you can see the documentary
there's a documentary on youtube al
jazeera i think
it talks about muslims converting to
slam in jails you know and why
and subhanallah the for those who know
about jails uh how it is
it's uh you know it's not easy there
especially if you're on you know for
murder and so on
and um the brothers there they stick
together like no one messes with the
muslim community
like they just don't do it you know what
i mean like yeah people have like you
know you got the
you got the whites you got the blacks
you got the
the essays the spaniards you got a bunch
of different groups
in jail but the muslims masha allah
kind of mind their own business but
they're protected they take care of
themselves
you know i mean you've heard even like
stories like prison guards
except in islam even in guantanamo like
i was watching the other day
was this uh i think it was his moroccan
or something from north africa anyway
and he was talking you know accusing
guantanamo and the guard that was taking
care of him in
his unit he became muslim and then went
to visit him in north africa and after
he was released
what a beautiful story like i think
people need to
ask themselves like how does it happen
how does that happen that
the relig you know the faith the way of
life that everyone's trying to attack
today
how is it bringing people
to it you know how is it that in
the only one pay attention to this
subhanallah look at this is powerful
this is this is this is
the only incident in the history of
mankind pretty much
correct you know people can correct me
from before i'm for what i understand
is where the conqueror
accepted the faith of the conquered and
that was in the case of the
of of of the mongols right the mongolian
[ __ ] that
swiped across europe across the world
they conquered everything
they smashed and they would build
pyramids of skulls
okay they instead of converting the
people to their way
and they had their own traditions and
their own religion
they converted to islam themselves you
know what i mean like
that is the only incident in the history
of mankind that i can
think of where it happened the other way
you know usually when people conquer
they bring their language their culture
they impose it on people
in this case they slowly became muslim
and that's how you know everything
stopped because if not these guys would
have gone
and on taking over the whole world
yeah man it's beautiful too that
like what you said like islam islam
really brings the uh
i say the humane part of people out
again it brings that like
that compassion and that love back out
because like
man you're saying that and it's
reminding me of like
seekers i've had this thing ever since i
was abused as a kid
where it's like i i feel like my
predatory senses are just snapped on all
the time
well i'll see people and i'll
automatically see like their weak points
their strong points and like if someone
turns their back to me
i don't know what it is but like all my
senses like start zoning in where it's
like i feel like a cat
about to attack prey and it's like i
told my friend i was like yo when
someone turns their back don't you feel
like just
putting them in like a sleeper or just
like kicking their legs out and he's
like no brother
what are you talking about i was like
like am i really the only one
and um bro once i came to islam like
that didn't leave unfortunately i still
have it but i
i know now that like that's
i don't have to be controlled by that i
can still be
you know peaceful i can still be loving
i don't have to let my ego
take over and everything and it's funny
man because
me and fire had gone to iceland
all right and when we went to iceland uh
at the time bro i was jahil i was
muslim uh fire and definitely muslim and
he had
he had some medication that he was
prescribed just in case
anything like if he started tripping out
something they had prescribed him
some xanax now fire didn't take any of
the xanax
my man he manned it through he didn't
need it at all
yeah basically we got i got prescribed
xanax for um
generalized anxiety but i was like bro i
know how pharmaceuticals work i'm not
going to take this bro so i just
i kept it bro but this is where it's
going to go in i still brought it with
me
just in case right because you never
know yeah yeah so we were there and we
were
about to go out for the night meet him
and um another brother and i
literally told him all day bro give me
the xanax and i took
one and the other dude took one as well
fire didn't take any either
we went downtown and i remember
bro the entire night even with the xanax
like i was just hyper focused like just
ready for anything to pop off like i i
was like a predator and my friend
the other dude was like yo relax like
calm down you look like you want to
fight everyone
so sorry angel uh i mean i don't know
but
it seemed have you maybe i'm not sure
how comfortable but
you've had some issues in the past some
abuse or something yeah when i was a kid
um this dude came into my life when i
want to say i was like 10
10 years old and he didn't leave my life
so i was like
maybe i want to say 18 or 19.
and it was uh physical abuse mental
abuse
verbal abuse all that stuff man so
yeah i could connect based on what you
were saying right now i could i could
understand that that's kind of what
happens
you heard that too uh no alhamdulillah i
had the different
kind of issues but yeah i hear it
because i work with a lot of abuse cases
so that's why i kind of connected to
what you're saying
so yeah yeah man it it's rough it
doesn't go away
like people think it doesn't heal from
it and it's like
you just learn to live with it you learn
to accept thing you learn to um
you learn to manage it exactly exactly
well yeah
yeah but and those emotions you know i
mean you're talking about that those
primal emotions of
um i always tell my son he's 12 right
now he's got the
temper you know and he's always like
disappointed with himself when he like
loses it you know
and you know i put him in mma like quite
some quite some time ago you know he's
he's a good fighter that's
a lot like he's still young but man if
he punches like i think
if he lands a good one on me he can like
you know he gets it on my chin he can
he can lay me down you know he's got
this this mean like upper you know
overhand you know mashaallah is a tough
man
so um i told him i said look man i said
you don't have to feel bad about it i
said allah has blessed you with this
power
and this energy the strength i said just
learn to manage it
just learn to manage and i told him take
khalid as your
as your roma you know it was the sword
of allah i mean the guy was a fighter
that's it he's just a fighter and he was
a lover as well i mean
if anyone knows khalid properly and i
encourage you
he was you know some people say i'm not
a lover i'm a fighter i'm not a fighter
i'm a lover
no khalid was both you know he was the
man and
um i mean he he was this guy
he was he was the man like he was and i
said just manage your
strength you know allah is giving you
that that ability um
you know just manage it manage those
energies don't don't suppress it because
the more you suppress it put it on the
carpet
it's not going to go away just channel
it in the right way and benefit the
ummah benefit islam with it
so that that made sense to him so he's
he's done a lot better
bro that's that is the truth
because i tried to suppress it when i
got into like the new age stuff
and and christianity and um
i think i was the softest individual
that i've ever seen in my life like if
you look back
to like my old like my first videos well
i was like really into this new age
stuff bro you'll be like oh man
like this this dude's cake versus like
now
i'm i'm muslim and it's like yes i've
softened
but it's more so like i've become
compassionate
and i'm i'm real i'm human i still have
that aspect i'm not suppressing it but
it's like
now i have this whole different uh
complexity
to uh my my uh i guess you say emotions
my
expression personality whatever you want
to say
yeah you said new ways like those people
that believe in like
the universe and like that type of thing
yeah
so is that atheist or what not
agnostic agnostic it's kind of like
agnostic
um they believe the universe but it's
very
like me me me it's all about me
and and the love that they say is still
me
and anything that they speak about
there's no substance to what they're
talking about oh
okay so they call it law of attraction
not like cover
yeah right law of attraction
i did i did you got in psychedelic so
yeah i did you know how we perform zikr
um right
yeah in in new ways so they they perform
positive affirmations
and bro i will lie hero i would wake up
and i would set a timer for like 10-15
minutes
and i think for those 10-15 minutes i
would just repeat to myself
uh i am confident i am powerful
or i am i don't know some
dumb people and yeah some dumb stuff and
like people be like oh that's empowering
and you know i get it it has its side
but it's like
you perform the thicker like you you
bringing that guy consciousness that
taqwa you're bringing yourself back
to the creator and it's like that's
that's a hundred times better
than doing something for yourself
because like when you worship the
creator
you're actually benefiting yourself more
than if you were
i know what i'm saying yeah but positive
affirmations are okay like you can have
this uh
you know cognitive behavior therapy or
what i call an nlp in your
language you know where you like talk to
yourself it's okay
to talk to himself uh and encourage
himself and you know like have like this
this dialogue with yourself so there's
nothing wrong with that inshallah
but uh i must say bro i'm gonna like uh
i looked at some of your videos and all
that
man like the transformation is just this
is crazy bro
mashallah it's amazing
right yes it's not just like the
humbleness yes it's the byproduct you
know but the
the mentality bro like the you know the
the the philosophy
of life you know i mean because that's
the one thing that people can be very
nice you know you find
nice people some of the nice some very
nice people i met were atheists
like very good manners and very good you
know behavior
punctual you know put some muslims to
shame you know
but when you look at their philosophy of
life you know it was just
messed up like when you get into those
deep discussions about the universe
about the creator about just life in
general
about ethics and morals yeah these
people will be very nice during the day
they'll stick to professionalism and
whatnot but then man if the night comes
and
or the weekend or something like that
like those ethics are suspended
and things can get really messed up you
know what i mean to the point where like
what is this so yeah i mean it's about
the mind and the heart and of course the
good manners and all that are humbleness
it just you know comes with it you know
but mashallah i mean
goes to say see the change
that islam brings you know to the heart
to the mind to the soul to
to everything because it's it's a way of
life you know if you take it as a
religion it's like okay it's a religion
you know it's good there's philosophy
and there's
you know goodness to do this do that but
islam like
covers every aspect of life like you
don't have to invent
something you know and within its frame
of work it allows you
certain flexibilities allows you for you
know
the the accommodation of time and place
and location and culture and this and
that
within the boundaries of islam so that's
i would say one of the evidence for
islam being the truth that you're never
left in a corner to say like what should
i do now or like
we're stuck now we have to like come up
with our own things and whatnot you know
it's just not like that so that's that's
amazing bro i mean subhanallah you know
amazing yeah man that's why that's why i
love islam
and i love the fact that you know i
don't know much
in terms of uh the studies of islam like
the hadith
and um all the books that are available
like i've read the quran
al hamdulillah i'm reading it second
time i know the prayers
i know how to do a thicker and i'm do
i meditate and i try to be as present as
possible in everything that i do
but the thing is like even with islam
even when someone doesn't
have extensive knowledge your actions
speak for themselves and like when when
we speak there's a lot of room for
misinterpretation
you know like i could say one thing but
you're going to get from that what you
want to get from this truck
you know and like when when we do things
our actions
there's very little room for
misinterpretation because the actions
speak louder than the words
so it's beautiful like just how you said
that story
about the aki the the african-american
big dude
tattoos gold teeth didn't murder was in
jail for 30 years
it's like dude his actions spoke louder
than any of his words
yeah that's true man i mean allah says
very straight up man like this exactly
what you say all you believe
why do you say what you don't do
okay it's very powerful man why do you
say
what you don't do um actions are
definitely as you said man like yes you
have to have the iman understanding
but mostly reflected through your
actions that's why throughout the quran
you will see these
two um these two terms
paired together i don't even know how
many times but in latina
those who believe so you have the faith
the understanding
the theory and then you work you do the
righteous deeds the good deeds so it
doesn't say
what or like you know the the words the
good words no
it says those who believe and do and
work
and show it by action that's the
beautiful thing about islam and
even the word islam even though it
it is a noun but is it like an act of
islam itself
means action it means submission and the
form the arabic form of it the
definition of it if you look at the
if you analyze it it is a
a term that requires action
it means submission and which means work
which means doing
things it's not just believing things
it's doing things i think that's
probably one of our greatest problems in
this ummah today is that we are quite
good at talking
at philosophizing we're good at debating
intellectually
we're quite granting we have an issue
there in terms of
what we're presenting but the actions a
lot of times don't match
what we believe definitely there's a lot
of people in the ummah who are ignorant
no doubt about it but then again not
everyone has to be a scholar
right as anger said is
the way islam came it came to manage it
was sent to manage the
fitra the humanity allah's creators in a
certain way
and then he has sent for us this
deen to be the operating system so we
are the hardware
we are the computer the laptop whatever
okay and then the operating system
is islam if you put the wrong operating
system on a computer it's not even if it
powers on
even if it works to an extent it's not
going to be optimal
when you put the right operating system
on it it's going to work well you know
you're going to get the best out of it
that's kind of like what you know
for lack of better words
belongs the best of of examples
but islam is is there to to
manage your your natural disposition the
way allah created you
your emotions your thoughts your actions
your this and that
it demarcates certain things and it
tells you how you should
behave okay the theory like
what you should do but it also tells you
what to do if you
fail to do that or if you fall short you
know what happens after you make me mess
up or you make a mistake
how do you come back how do you take you
know a turn
it it tells you all those things right
so a lot of times yes
in um we deal with what we should do
but not many people talk about the
aftermath of our
actions or our words or what we do how
do we get back how do we fix things how
do we
do damage control and so on because
let's face it a lot of people
as the prophet saw sallam said in that
beautiful hadith
every son and daughter of adam makes
mistakes or sins right everyone
every single one right so that's the
beautiful thing
how do you get back and the best of
those sinners or those
people make mistakes or those who make
told antoba
linguistically means a change a return
come back
again requires action it's just not
necessarily just
a thing of the lips right so it's it's
beautiful because
when you understand islam on a deeper
level
that doesn't mean you have to know all
the books and
some people do alhamdulillah we need
that
but others don't
but you need to have a foundation basics
basics are the are very important
and that is you know what we
build on the basics on the foundation of
islam
monotheism the messengers you know the
the articles of faith the pillars of
faith
that's what we build on as for the
details some people know them
some people spend their life studying
them and that is
what we need of course and in general
most people we call in arabic or in the
film a worm
or general lay men just normal people
you know some of them are fighters some
of our businessmen some are doctors some
of them are this other that you know it
depends right
but definitely every person has to seek
knowledge
every person has to know certain amount
of knowledge
enough for them to make sure they
perform their
acts of worship they don't wrong anyone
they don't do anything wrong
and then as for the details of the
different sciences and so on this is
something that is
you know only certain people get into it
this is the beautiful thing we're
one nation together what i don't know
you're gonna back me up
you don't know i'm gonna back you up
that's that's why the unity is so
important
to be together now
sex and forgive me
forgive me if i'm if i'm going to be
wrong here
because i'm again i am reaver y'all know
this
uh but the way that i understand it is
that
islam is the perfect template
it's it's the perfect instruction manual
it's like look
do this it aligns with your natural
religion
if you never knew about islam this is
going to align exactly with what's
going to be your natural religion your
natural way of life
i mean just look at people who aren't
exposed to
civilizations to countries or or just
the governments and all that stuff
like people living in nature in the wild
like in
in the peruvian what is it the the
amazon does
not does it dry fast got me you know the
dry fast got me right now the uh
the amazon jungle these people out there
like they're very pure now obviously you
know they believe in
some stuff that might be a little far
it's reaching
but like the internal aspect the core
beliefs of what they're doing
is pretty much in line with the fitra
you know and i feel like i agree with
you
that um you know it's not enough to just
believe but you also have to do you need
the actions and
and that's why i feel like there is kind
of an issue
because a lot of the uh brothers and
sisters in the uma
they're quick to correct another person
on something that they're doing wrong
which okay beautiful
like i'm y'all can't see me that way i'm
gonna try to
screwed up so i got some more light here
but um
they're quick to to correct one person
on what they're doing which is cool
you know i love that because i want to
be corrected if i'm doing something
wrong
but um are they doing what they have to
be doing like are they pious
are they great are they righteous are
they making sure that their house is in
order before
they try to tell another person how to
live their life
you got to think about it too like this
is the theme
and the deen is the way of life and that
way of life
though we all have the same template is
going to be different for each
individual
whereas you have people who come to
islam
from prison from being in gangs from
murdering
from doing all this crazy stuff that you
have these people
go over here in war you all have these
people who are growing up in the streets
just fighting
you know these people that are just
involved in drugs you have these people
that are um
i don't know just simple christians or
something like that and they come to
islam they come to the dean
everyone is going to be practicing it in
a different way they are going to be
trying to adhere to it
as perfectly as they can but your dean
may be slightly different than another
person be
yeah i think um yeah the thing is that
as you said the template is perfect and
we know what we have to do
you enter that template through
saying that is the key opens the door
you step
in and it's just perfect right and then
you start going through it
and then you're going to have definitely
things pulling your left and right in
this world sometimes pulling you back
from your past
things that you've done in the past you
know sometimes you you know you might
forgiving yourself you might been
forgiven by allah but you just sometimes
cannot forget and i think a lot of
people have not come from jahiliyyah
from the old
days they don't understand that they
might not understand what it means
to carry that bag and yeah they got to
be easy on it now of course if someone
commits shirk or does something major
right then yeah definitely you want to
make sure you point that out
but you know like to pick on people for
like you know bro i have tattoos you
know
it's like well that was before i slept
oh but you should take it off you know
you should remove it or something like
that you know what i mean
like okay i have tattoos i cannot remove
it right now it's not the most practical
thing we know
very well that islam forgives everything
that happened before
this is something i've done before you
know what i mean i mean i cannot
you know take it off so some people pick
on funny things you know and that's
something different but if someone as
you said
someone corrects you on a major thing
you've done something wrong in terms of
you know your your faith or your
practice then yeah correct me bismillah
you know it's very important people get
very sensitive don't even when it comes
to corrections
so yes we have to correct but at the
same time as you said right everyone is
going to have a different struggle
um practicing wise you know we're all
praying five times a day we all have to
do the same
things correctly as well as we can um
you know
and fear allah as much as you can you
know that's why allah tells in the quran
fear allah have taqwa of allah as much
as you can meaning
as you said do your best like try to
adhere to this perfect template
the best will you do it properly
perfectly 100 no
we see the sahaba made some some
interesting and very you know i don't
want to say i'm always very careful with
the
words yeah because again i get a lot of
smack you know from from the
the people watching sometimes so i'm
always like very aware of that
because i i do i don't want to turn
people off you know what i mean i want
people to listen and to understand what
we're talking about
so sahabas did make some some major
um i don't want to say mistakes i guess
yeah
um no doubt they're the best because
allah says allah is pleased with them
and they are pleased with him so they
are endorsed by allah
but throughout the seat of the prophet
sam we see a lot of these issues
happening
now does that disqualify them no they're
the best
and that's i think what we need did they
have issues like did they make shirk or
something or like
you know go to graves and worship saints
and all that no
no no these were these were procedural
issues
in their practice and certain things
that they've done right that they've
made wrong so for example you know the
guy came to the process and we talked
about yesterday
and he made suju to him right like
you're not allowed to make jesus
but he felt to him that he loved the
process him so much that he wanted to
make sujud
to him in the process him
you know he didn't like you know
chastise him like that but he just
he gave him something to understand no
this is not correct
right this is not correct even though in
the previous
scriptures we see yusuf alaysalam
prophet joseph that his family makes
you to him prostration out of
thankfulness and out of
uh respect like the angels did to adam
but the process him said no because of
how people have used that the wrong way
now it's not allowed anymore if i were
to order anyone to prostrate i would
have ordered the woman to prostrate to
the men you know
the wife to the husband and we discussed
the implication of the hadith
but yeah we see the way he corrected
people and the way he
and yes sometimes he would get very
upset if the rules of allah would be
broken or if people try to change the
dean
anything like that but in terms of
correcting procedural mistakes
mistakes within the social sphere
the social practice of things the
prophet sallam was was an
expert in doing that and it would make
you
come closer to him and be more attracted
to the faith as opposed to
leave you with it like a bitter taste in
your mouth and just like
you know walk away and get upset right
subhanallah i wanted to point something
out
are you are you familiar with a brother
by the name of elliot
you guys i am i'm going to head out it
is
7 50. i lost track of time
don't worry go for it man that was a
good discussion man
it was it was i'm just give me 20
seconds i want you here while i say this
okay so do you know this guy named also
now
ellia elliot i've heard about him yeah
he has like three million subscribers
he's pretty big on youtube but
we did uh our episode that dropped
yesterday was with him
and we gave him like we just wanted to
have a conversation we just wanted to
talk about islam
and his views and kind of create some
common ground allah says in the quran
like
make good with you know the people of
the book and that's
it now people are here in the comments
and people are always going to say
something right people out here in the
comments saying
you know you guys could have said this
you guys could have done that and it's
like bro the purpose wasn't to give
dawah by
words but more so by by you know example
common ground and
maybe inshallah he's a christian by the
way if you haven't already noticed but
huh he's catholic that's a christian bro
it's all friends to me
it's the same thing but yeah but but him
essentially we still make the world that
he finds slam and everyone finds the
song but
that's it it's like people were out here
raping us for that you feel me
and i was just like come on bro my
brother like think about it like this
okay think about it like this like did
we
specifically make dawah trying to make
him convert or trying to make him see
the truth
no but with our actions we did the best
that we could it's like bro who knows
who knows if we soften him up to where
one point
sure he'll he'll remember the
conversation be like yo
i might be this much more willing yeah
he's probably going to look at your
stuff he's probably going to look at you
guys he's probably going to look at you
guys start the podcast and all that
check you guys out
here you go but that's essentially the
point i'm trying to you know
bring it full circle and bring home to
gabriel but that's going to make him
want to come back
it's it didn't leave that bitter taste
in his mouth like you said you know
the people that are doing comments bro
these people don't have youtube channels
they're not giving dollars they're not
they're just at home watching watching
stuff all day
if you are you are but it's like at the
end of the day you can't think
with this whole pressure like this whole
rushing thing like you need la la la by
the end of every episode
but you gotta you gotta play the long
game and lead by example if you can't do
anything
and that's right it is actually
and the last thing i'm going to say uh
we had a guest on here by the name of
sheikh bahad are you recognizing yeah he
said um
the heart can't be won over with logic
and with rationale and i mean that's
true
there are very few people who you
approach them rationally about islam and
they'll be like ah
okay i'm just gonna put everything aside
and i'm just gonna accept it i'm gonna
become muslim here
right here you ready for this you ready
for this so jude is the only position
where the heart is over the mind
[Music]
wishes to you in this uh day of fasting
the sixth day for you
and fireball enjoy your food once you
get off
all right bro being hi bro we're all
just getting off let's just end it off
yeah all right all right i will let if
brother gabriel started this we will end
this often
may
yes sir do what you can stop worrying
about what you can't
um and again you go to hell you go to
hell
i'm just playing um if you think you're
gonna go to hell
it's probably because you're not doing
everything you could be doing so
i do say do what you can don't worry
about what you can't but
what people think they can't is often
much smaller than what they actually can
you feel me like people think they can't
do a lot of things
but trust me nothing is farther from the
truth
[Music]
um
[Music]
um